this video is brought to you by Wix
hello my fellow truth warriors Jared
here today I want to continue a
conversation started in our Flat Earth
video conspiracy theories Pete I mean
totally honest and rigorous searches for
truth art having a moment in modern
culture there are people who think
Robert Mueller was unearthing a
pedophile ring people who think a
milania's from body double regularly
appears with president
people who think vaccines are giving all
our kids autism and cancer and of course
flat earthers who will be having their
own cruise in 2020 proposing that a
secret plot exists to hide the truth
from the average citizen is not new for
years we've been asking questions like
who really killed JFK did we really land
on the moon is the government hiding
aliens but I'm not here to destroy these
arguments with facts and logic instead I
want to talk about how conspiracy
theories are different today namely that
they're a microcosm of a much larger
issue that the idea of expertise is
slowly evaporating so join me as we dive
into why this matters in this wisecrack
edition on conspiracy theories and no
spoilers ahead this time but before we
get into it want to give a shout-out to
this video sponsor wicks whether you're
just finishing up school or on the hunt
for a new gig the best way to showcase
your skills is with a website I recently
created one using Wix and had a lot of
fun customizing my site no matter your
professional expertise Wix makes it easy
to create a website to show off your
work whether you're a writer a creative
or something else there are hundreds of
templates that require no coding skills
and are completely free to use so head
over to Wix calm slash wisecrack or
click the link right here to get started
and now back to the show most conspiracy
theories are founded on an extreme
distrust of so-called experts flat
earthers don't trust physicists at nasa
anti-vaxxers don't trust their
physicians or the fda and q and on
doesn't trust anyone in the deep state
unless they happen to be surreptitiously
unraveling the truth of pizza gate or
something to find out how we lost belief
in our experts so thoroughly we first
need to go to the birth of the idea of
expertise the expert is a fairly recent
invention
his book nervous states democracy and
the decline of Reason sociologists will
Davies locates the birth of an expert
class in the wake of the destructive
religious Wars of the 17th century when
tons of Protestants and Catholics murder
each other people had to grapple with a
basic question in a world recently
ravaged by hatred how do we build a
world based on trust rather than fear or
anger Thomas Hobbes gave one solution
writing in 1651 he argued that a strong
governments scaring the crap out of
everyone would instill trust between
subjects if you cheated stole or
murdered you had a big bad Leviathan ie
the sovereign waiting to dish out
justice at the same time the merchant
class had a similar crisis of trust how
can I trust that this person can pay me
back
merchants and Finance ears faced the
same problem with the world's monarchs
who are interested in raising large
armies with borrowed money how could I
trust the king or queen who promised
that they were good for it even the
scientists who armed with the scientific
method would go on to build the
foundations of our modern understanding
of the world had this problem how do I
trust other scientists who I've never
met and the observations they claim
they've made the answer was the expert
as Davies writes pioneering communities
of merchants and gentlemen introduced
strict new rules for how their
impressions should be recorded and
spoken up to avoid exaggeration and
distortion using numbers and public
record-keeping merchants began extensive
bookkeeping which could be scrutinized
by anyone looking to do business with
them Britain's Royal Society and
organizations seeking to advance science
had its foundations in trust of one's
peers members were allowed to debate
about theoretical issues with each other
but never questioned on another's
observation of an experiment essentially
if you spotted a new object in space
with your telescope we could debate
about what it was but not whether or not
you actually saw something the Bank of
England was formed in 1694 to bridge
another trust gap how could lenders know
the crown was good for the money they
borrowed the monarchy developed a
growing array of record-keeping
techniques in order to convince finance
ears that it could be trusted to honor
its debts this era also saw the rise of
coffee houses and an intellectual
culture within them that wielded
math to solve modern issues number files
who wanted to look at death rates birth
rates or the economy for instance these
coffee houses were also the birthplace
of the insurance industry where expert
underwriters could evaluate risk in a
transparent and objective manner while
all this may seem like a glaring
necessity of civilization the rise of
these experts marked a huge
transformation in how society works as
davies writes in the 1670s the
suggestion that political questions be
settled on the basis of numerical facts
was radical this idea now dominates the
modern world as most aspects of life are
dictated by bureaucrats and public
policy but sentiment towards these
experts seems to have changed for
anti-vaxxers medical doctors are blindly
handing out vaccines ignorant of their
dangerous effects for flat-earthers
basic observations are contested if when
an astronomers spotted an object in the
cosmos during the age of the Royal
Society we might believe them and try to
replicate that observation today there's
no room for trust this basic lack of
trust is mirrored in this quote from
Patricia steer-in Netflix's Flat Earth
documentary an event like a I'll just
use Boston bombing again I'm not going
to believe any of those events are real
and less than myself I get my leg blown
up this is a common refrain for flat
earthers only believe what your own eyes
tell you science just throws math at us
whereas we go and say hey by the way
there's Seattle you can see it right now
with your camera that's it a picture
says a thousand words this kind of
thinking is an overt rejection of the
very idea of expertise as Davies writes
to trust in science is to trust in the
capacity of people to report and record
things in an adequate fashion we're
willing to take their word for it rather
than constantly refer back to the thing
itself this rejection marks a shift in
conspiracy theories older conspiracy
theories like those surrounding the JFK
assassination or the moon landing might
exhibit a distrust of the government and
take some interpretive leaps and to be
fair the government has done its fair
share of shady things these older
theories might try to make sense of the
life-changing events of the day in a
world where one felt cheated or
disempowered they helped bring order
and clarity but many of today's popular
theories according to professor Nancy
rosenbloom are all conspiracy and no
theory the purpose of conspiracy
theories is no longer to explain reality
or offer some account of the world
instead the point is to erode trust in
public figures or institutions there's
perhaps no better example of this than
Flat Earth who unlike other conspiracy
theories only offers the flimsiest of
motivations for why a governing body
would lie about the shape of the earth
so when it comes to science think of it
this way if you have 450 years of them
showing you it's a globe how much is
that worth to them to keep it it's worth
everything
whereas a faked moon landing could
plausibly be motivated in the context of
the Cold War with the space race and all
the best motivation flat-earthers can
dig up is some vague plot to keep us
dumb and buying stuff they want people
dumb blind deaf to the truth so they can
inject you with their vaccines and their
public schooling if previous popular
conspiracies were centered around
history changing events 9/11 the moon
landing the assassination of JFK today's
conspiracy theories like pizza gate just
seem to be pulled out of thin air
there's no momentous event that demands
our reaction in the Flat Earth
documentary for instance Star flat
earther mark Sargent admits the entire
movement was birthed from him randomly
looking at a dusty book on the shelf
when you get bored enough with normal
conspiracies you're looking for
something new there was a certain
novelty to it anti-vaxxers on the other
hand may not be pulling from thin air
like pizza gate or flat earth they are
in theory reacting to concerns over
autism rates and at least their villain
has a reasonable motivation would
pharmaceutical companies put profits
over people probably but like other
modern conspiracy theories anti-vaxxers
seek to attack people's trust and elites
a fair share of anti-vaxxer evangelism
doesn't try to recruit you so to speak
but too slowly so doubt about the safety
of vaccinations and the trustworthiness
of pediatricians even parents who
haven't officially hopped aboard the
anti vaccine may opt not to get a flu
vaccine because of some manufactured
concern about mercury or cancer and
after all
who dies from the flu for Rosenblum the
point is to erode faith in institutions
the medical establishment the scientific
establishments anything you can slap the
word establishment on outside of
conspiracy theories however a similar
lack of trust permeates our society and
not all for bad reasons today
government's think tanks and other
organizations are full of quote experts
touting solutions to modern problems for
instance economists who armed with facts
and figures know exactly what monetary
policy we need to implement or if the
economy is growing or shrinking these
proclamations especially when proposed
with an air of certainty should be
looked at critically so while we might
be wistful for the days when we trusted
the people who knew things it's
important to remember that this wasn't a
utopia like all things experts come with
their fair share of problems it turns
out experts are a great help in invading
and conquering foreign lands or even
putting down rebellions as Davies notes
and the main customers of the affer
mention nascent insurance industry were
slave ships looking to insure their
human cargo other research has suggested
that there's no purely rational thinking
as even expert thought is unavoidably
affected by emotion today people view
expertise as in service to something
else an agenda emotions a conspiratorial
plot and so on for instance while some
economists will point to the GDP for a
recovering economy first quarter GDP and
it is a whopper others will look at
median wages middle-class folks are
starting to get paid as much as they did
before the recession or unemployment
rates or the percentage of people living
in poverty even a basic statistic like
how many people live in poverty comes
with debates about what exactly defines
the poverty line the point is many
elites will point to whatever metric
makes their camp look better so it's
hard to unilaterally condemn this
suspicion of them you don't need to be a
conspiracy theorist to know that experts
can and do have political agendas or
they simply fail to see the collateral
damage of their policies Davies writes
that the resentment of elites that we
see around us today is fueled by a sense
that the promise of experts is now bogus
revelations of their personal moral
failings via media expose zli
and social media searches make the
distinction of these figures ever harder
to sustain their claim to represent our
interest becomes nothing but a shroud
for their own political agendas and
that's why this distrust level that
experts is so complicated it's sometimes
justified sometimes not but it raises a
much deeper problem for society as
rosenbloom argues it's not just trust in
institutions or science that's at risk
but our trust in each other whereas
older conspiracy theories often targeted
those at the table the wealthy elites
pulling the strings
today's conspiracy theories often target
people on the bottom as well survivors
of school shootings who are called
crisis actors scientists and teachers
deemed Spheeris chills pizza shop owners
labeled pedophiles and YouTube channels
theorized to be fronts for the
Illuminati at the same time people at
the top who were formerly the
perpetrators of conspiracies can now be
the victim like say people in the
highest offices of government Davies
argues that our lack of trust and elites
or each other has resulted in a kind of
Hobbesian war of all against all it's
not that we want to murder each other
but that in any kind of disagreement we
distrust the basic premise of our
so-called opponents they're either a
hypocrite a liar politically tainted or
so on the phrase virtue signaling for
instance is not an attack on the virtue
itself but rather a statement that it's
done in authentically similarly
arguments have become a place to win
this so-called war rather than to seek
truth the Internet has become not a
place to advance knowledge but a place
to go to see people destroyed or dumped
on in the game of truth and it's this
gamification of truth that is
particularly worrisome beyond the
internet we see tons of knowledge
produced VirB think tanks lobbyists or
advocacy groups and while some might
simply suggest that a marketplace of
ideas will separate the good ideas from
the bad
Davy's warns that the facts alone won't
save us
there is no overwhelming victory of
truth against fiction especially on the
Internet
while some platforms have recently
cracked down on conspiracy theory
content paranoia and fear are still
incredibly shareable we could also ask
if they
News and post truth are more symptoms of
arguments accelerating to the point
where only superficial judgments are
possible as Davies writes
instead he suggests we defend slowness
the ability to restrain our impulse
toward reactivity and commit ourselves
to thoughtfulness so what do you think
wisecrack how can we continue to build a
society based on trust while still
promoting healthy skepticism and
criticism or do we truly live in a post
truth society thanks to all our patrons
who support the channel and our podcasts
don't forget to hit that subscribe
button and be sure to check out Wix at
wix.com slash wisecrack to build your
own website for free and as always
thanks for watching guys peace
[Music]
[Applause]